[Music]
I'm Adam Taylor and this is the
classroom we opened here on the
conferences in November 2016 but we've
been in Westgate since 2004. primarily
we do nutrition so we do maths and
English tuition we take from year three
right up to GCSE and now we're just like
back on a levels as well for maths so
2004 started the franchise called Kumon
Kumon mass in English and we did that
until 2009 when basically we grouped up
independently completely as the
classroom and never look back and we
take these Kent generally speaking so
we've got right down to Ashford Dover in
terms of the actual tuition because
we're online we're going to take from
anywhere so we've got some we can do
Post out to we've got one currently
saying in Manchester and we've had them
in London Liverpool a few other places
but we want to actually keep local as
much as possible anyway uh main reason
is the children have the classes online
but I actually deliver the homework to
people as well so I twice a week I'm out
delivering homework around East Kent
doing
um I'll do 1400 miles a month mainly
delivering work out to people
um fortunately all electric now we've
always had a small book shop here uh
when since 2016 but when we moved
everything online with the pandemic we
actually decided to redo it properly as
a children's Bookshop and we just yeah
trying to do much as we can for the
community
three story events because a lot of
children are affected by by the pandemic
the youngest ages and we also are doing
a reindeer Trail we're doing coming up
soon we want residents involved
businesses involved if possible
so children got something free to do to
get out walk around you know that week
before Christmas get some exercise
hopefully some good weather and just
enjoy it and have some free like
Christmas time because obviously
everything's expensive it's very
important to keep shopping locals
supporting your neighbors
um financially emotionally everyone as
well so it's all yeah very very
important to do that and yeah we all
just got to work together wait to see
you get through the next 12 months or so
thank you